le service des petites annonces de
libération n'a sûrement jamais publié
autant de petits mots d'amour saint
valentin oblige le romantisme fait un
retour en force mais il a aussi un prix
de 30 à 75 euros pour quelques mots pour
une photo alexandre haga jean jacques
botti
ils s'aiment et le monde c'est le plus
beau des clichés celui qu'offre
aujourd'hui paris à tous les amoureux
une photo gratuite prise par un
professionnel place de l'hôtel de ville
comme si l'ombre de doisneau planète
encore sur la capitale des amours
attaquera kitsch je pensais qu'ils
allaient refuser et y'a pas refuser un
deuxième petit bébé donc tout seul plus
on peut immortaliser histoire ici mon
ami vient d'europe
moi je viens barcelone alors on a fait
de paris
notre point de lui qu'on est marié quand
même photo et petites annonces ont deux
classiques qui ont toujours la cote
preuve que l'amour en compte encore des
chemins traditionnels en 2005 pour
déclarer sa flamme christophe a choisi
le journal libération comme samson
autres personnes qui préfèrent le papier
aux sms ou e mail
c'est une déclaration qu'on fait devant
tout le monde
mais en même temps c'est un peu caché
c'est relativement anonyme il ya que la
personne qui la reçoit tu peux la
comprendre
donc c'est ce mélange de surprise et
puis d'anonymat qui m'a plu le coût est
élevé de 30 à 75 euros selon le nombre
de mots mais l'effet est garanti 5
millions de lecteurs ont feuilleté le
journal aujourd'hui pour y découvrir les
tendances amoureuse 2005 une écriture
assez fraîches c'est un vrai retour au
romantisme et aux côtés crête
préférerait jusque dans les années 80 où
les discours pouvait être parfois plus
crue dans les propos s'inquiète pas tu
auras contrées dont petit string rouge
comme il se doit je t'aime drôle
petit plus cette année chantal thomass
fait partie d'un jury qui récompense les
trois meilleurs messages d'un voyage
très différentes les unes des autres et
les choses très simples je t'aime mon
très simple il ya des choses très drôle
des mots d'humour
enfin c'est mignon mais beaucoup de
choses très romantique perdant ou
gagnant ils s'aiment et se le dise
et c'est bien là le plus important